joining me now is mishavon schatz his
family owns the aforementioned russian
sum of our restaurant which is one of
the most famous in new york city's
theater district
misha it's good to see you tonight now i
understand
you've had to hire security guards
are things really that bad
uh it's more of a preventative uh we
have a lot of our staff is feeling uh
uneasy so they asked us to high security
for the coming weeks
uh it's always best to be
safe than sorry so we're going through
with that we also been getting a lot of
crazy phone calls threats i mean just
today alone we're doing all the the
press we've had about
i don't know i can't even count maybe
six or eight
it's pretty pretty tough right now what
do you say to folks who are
watching this tonight um
you've
were you born in this country are you
born in uh former soviet union where are
you
so no no so i'm first generation
american my father's ukrainian from uh
odessa my mother's from leningrad now st
petersburg russia
uh i grew up in the russian samurai
which was a safe haven for everybody
that defected the oppression of the
soviet union this is a place for
intelligence and everybody to meet the
founders were my grandfather roman
kaplan
mikhail barishnikov and joseph brodsky
so my message to people is pretty much
you know do do not vilify anything
or anybody that is russian we did not
cause this war this is putin's war
just because we are a russian
establishment does not mean that we cut
a check to putin or his regime and this
is the message that i'm trying to convey
to to people to understand
now facebook made a stunning
announcement today misha meta platforms
will allow facebook and instagram users
in some countries
to call for violence against russians
and russian soldiers in the context of
the ukraine invasion according to
internal emails seen by reuters on
thursday and temporary changes to its
hate speech policy
um right
what
what oh misha your response to that yeah
yeah i mean i'm not surprised at the
same time shock sell cells
uh so it's very unfortunate you know and
especially coming out of this pandemic
with everything that we saw with the
asian hate and all everything tied to
coronavirus
you know it's very unfortunate and
especially after all the uh
you know the publicity and all the you
know the the cases going on with this
the fact that they haven't learned the
lesson is it's really disappointing and
i'm truly concerned i'm worried for my
family there my family here our workers
everything
now
there was i think a unified outcry
against
anti-asian hate
after the
the
pandemic began because it's just
blatantly unfair and horrible to do that
to people but nothing to do with the
pandemic
uh and this is no different absolutely
no it isn't and the worst part is a lot
of the the hate that we're getting is
people that aren't even ukrainian or
russian it just seems to be people that
want to be vigilantes and you know i
guess project their own inner feelings
of hatred towards anybody else any any
moment they can get which is very
unfortunate and unfortunate at the same
time we have to deal with the brunt of
that
well misha small business owners in new
york especially in washington dc all
these blue cities that stayed locked
down have suffered so much and now
you're going through one more round of
uh you know difficulty and uh we we
certainly hope you guys are okay and it
never ends it's not it's never not it's
never ending it's just being a joke
people don't go out and support your
russian establishment
please yeah everybody needs it misha
thank you hey sean hannity here hey
click here to subscribe to fox news
youtube page and catch our hottest
interviews and most compelling analysis
you will not get it anywhere else